[Música]
qual o personagem você interpreta na sua
vida
eu sei que muitos de vocês se
identificam com o personagem de filme
che de séries vocês quiseram se aquele
personagem pois podem ter sonhado que
vocês eram aquele personagem mas não
essa pergunta a pergunta qual o
personagem você interpreta na sua vida
mesmo de verdade sim porque todos nós
interpretamos personagens e eu vou
começar contando a vocês como eu
descobri que eu precisava interpretar
personagens eu era extremamente tímida
na escola e com 56 anos eu lembro de ter
pavor da hora do intervalo porque eu
ficava num campo sentada sozinha e pedia
por favor pra ninguém falar comigo
porque eu não conseguia interagir com
pessoas e aí foi recomendado fazer aulas
de teatro para começar a interagir nas
aulas de teatro eu aprendi que eu
precisava colocar máscaras para
conseguir enfim me relacionar
e isso não é uma técnica nova e roma
antiga se fala de persona que quer dizer
àquelas máscaras têm atrás que se coloca
para interpretar um personagem e esse
tempo persona depois começou a significa
máscara social papel social que todos
nós interpretamos quando você lida com
um colega de trabalho de faculdade e
você não conhece tudo da vida dele mas
você atribui um personagem a ele bem
então intuitivamente ainda sem pensar
muito eu me transformei numa mistura do
cid de a era do gelo com o burrinho do
shrek não era um bom personagem pra ser
eram personagens desajeitados e meio sem
saber o que estavam fazendo e aí eu
percebi que eu precisava conscientemente
criar um personagem e comecei a usar
série
pra isso porque os as séries pra isso
porque se eu pegar steve jobs se eu
pegar a gandhi se eu pega o madre teresa
de calcutá
qualquer um deles eles são ícones e
cones que eu admiro as ferramentas que
eu quero aprender a usar mas eu não sei
nem se eu me daria bem com eles
eu não sei quem eles são e eu não sei
como eles são em casa ou no trabalho
mas na série não eu acompanho o
personagem de série por vários e vários
anos
eu aprendo as fraquezas
eu vejo como eles têm perdas como eles
lidam com isso como eles amadurecem com
a vida muda de contexto
eles são personagens de fato eles são
muito próximos a mim e é por isso que a
gente vai trabalhar séries hoje a gente
vai ver como eles conseguiram me ajudar
a criar um personagem como eles podem
ajudar vocês a criarem personagens
então eu vou começar pela criação desse
personagem era uma vez um personagem de
uma série que não fala de
empreendedorismo que não está nos
manuais e artigos sobre frases
impactantes empreendedoras de séries
al-ahmed chamada é uma série a onde o
personagem principal ou ted que vocês
vêm aí ele narra os filhos como ele
conheceu a esposa dele e quando ele
conta para os filhos dele sueli vai
contando como foi a inserção
profissional dele como era o contexto
dia a dia uma série bem água com açúcar
bem bem diária e o ted é arquiteto
assim como eu o ted é engraçado como as
profissões têm a ver com quem a gente é
o ted
ele é representado como quase todos os
arquitetos de filmes e séries ele é um
cara gente boa
despojado criativo sonhador demais e com
uma vida amorosa complicada
eu acho que eu já falei para vocês que
eu me identifico com ele então o pede a
um pouquinho
deming eo curioso ou a primeira edição
que lhe dá mais importante é que todos
nós todos nós às vezes somos limitados
pelo que o universo as pessoas dizem que
a gente pode ser isso é pouco
só a gente lá no fundo sabe o que a
gente pode ser de fato eu acho que no
começo da adolescência a gente tem uma
frase do eu vou ser eu vou ser
presidente eu vou ser se ou eu vou ser o
maior e mais rico empresário do mundo
eu vou fazer tom arrogante que a gente
geralmente não dividir ela nem com o
nosso melhor amigo porque se a gente
divide ele provavelmente vai dar nossa
cara e aquela massagem do ego do eu vou
ser muito grande vai desaparecer e seu
amigo disse pra você que quer ser
presidente acredite ele quer muito mais
do que isso a gente nunca difícil essa
frase com ninguém mas é essa frase e só
essa frase que tem que motivar todos
vocês
você não tem que se conformar com o
próximo cargo a qual você não tem que
confiar conformar com os puxa sacos que
você pode ter porque você hoje ocupa uma
posição importante você tem que pensar
aonde você quer chegar de fato e até de
falar sobre isso mas o teste também na
sua busca pelo amor da sua vida
ele também tem uma coisa curiosa ele
começa a achar que o amor da sua vida
uma mulher de uns sobrando e sombrinha
amarela que tá aí representada na cena e
aí o spoiler
esse não é o amor da vida dele o amor da
vida dele é uma melhor amiga que esteve
do lado dele durante toda a série
isso ensina pra gente que às vezes
muitas vezes a gente e se pede se
desvirtuam e fica procurando a sombrinha
amarela e fica perseguindo aquilo não é
aquilo que a gente quer
não é isso que vai levar a gente para
onde a gente deveria está eo que separa
o pessoal os ordinários dos
extraordinários é que os extraordinários
não deixaram a sua frase eu quero ser
pra trás
os ordinários e conformaram com o
próximo passo que eles vão dar
cuidado com as sombrinhas amarelas que
vão aparecer na vida de vocês porque
elas eram muitas
aí eu passo por um outro personagem da
série grey's anatomy a série grey's
anatomy trata de uma unidade de saúde
emergencial onde eu tenho médico seus
residentes a vida e quando um pouquinho
da vida profissional pessoal desses
médicos e tem um personagem o board que
é um personagem que está nas primeiras
temporadas e que ele nos ensinou uma
coisa muito importante e o meu
personagem o personagem de vocês precisa
ter isso ele é baleado em um determinado
momento e ele pede ele pede a mobilidade
da mão ele não tem mais firmeza imagem o
cirurgião sem firmeza e ele entra em uma
crise existencial e agora o que é que
você que aconteceu comigo e ele corta um
frango no meio alguns frangos e começa a
sutura esses frangos imagine o maior
cirurgião do mundo superando frangos
para conseguir mobilidade na mão o que
isso diz pro meu personagem que ele
precisa ser capaz de dar um passo atrás
nem tudo gente é dar passos à frente a
gente precisa dar passos atrás para ver
a situação e para melhorar os nossos
pontos fracos sim porque todos nós temos
pontos fracos
nós não somos perfeitos e aí porque logo
depois da sua recuperação ele desde que
aquele contexto aquele emprego aquela
vida que ele leva não faz mais sentido
ele muda para outro continente ele vai
pra europa constrói uma nova carreira
recebe prêmios por isso e sempre mas a
questão é será que às vezes a gente não
tá fixado na mesma página da vida aquela
vida tem um monte de coisa escrita
coisas legais que a gente viveu e que
tem uma sombrinha amarelo aí que a gente
não quer largar ea gente precisa virar a
página o tempo todo senão a gente vai
ficar no mesmo lugar
e lembrem que a gente precisa ser
extraordinário igual a voz que temos
dentro da gente e aí eu chego ao
terceiro personagem que
inspirar quem somos que é o professor de
lá a casa de papel na casa de papel
conta a história de um roubo à casa da
moeda e o professor é o grande
estrategista é a pessoa que pensa como é
que isso vai ser feito
sabe o que ele nos ensina que a gente
precisa olhar o nosso adversário
estrategicamente
às vezes a gente tem uma pessoa concorre
com a gente a gente se limita a dizer se
veste mal ou a gente olha nós
concorrente fala acordo outdoor dele não
está boa
isso não vai nos ajudar quando o
professor analisa a polícia e não
analisa uniforme da polícia esse acordo
é bonita ou feia ele analisa como a
polícia age estrategicamente e por isso
o plano dele começa a dar certo
quando eu olho meu concorrente eu tenho
que entender a estratégia dele eo que
ele tenha me ensinar porque se não
entender a estratégia dele eu vou me
fixar em pequenos detalhes que não fazem
sentido
e aí eu entro na personagem que eu mais
gosto a personagem que eu quero ser o
que o tempo ser é essa personagem de
larry the game of thrones game of
thrones tem um enredo bastante complexo
mas muito simplificadamente pra quem não
conhece bem o futebol lhes trata da
disputa de cinco líderes pelo trono de
ferro e você é o rei de fato desses
cinco povoados e ela é uma dessas
candidatas uma dessas cinco candidatas
ea de nelas começa extremamente frágil
ela é frágil ela começa casando com um
cara que ela não quer casar porque o
irmão disse que ela ia precisava fazer
aquilo e ela foge e chega um momento que
ela descobre a força interior que ela
tem e aí ela começa a ser uma líder de
fato sabe o que a dell está bem
diferente dos outros
ela não tentou meter medo nos seus
liderados os liderados delas seguem ela
por que a admiram e querem fazer isso
ela tem paixão nas suas atitudes
ela não é base e uma coisa interessante
que a de mulheres conta pra gente sobre
o personagem que precisamos ter é ela
passa toda essa constituição
esse crescimento para ocupar o trono de
ferro e dado momento que esse momento
que tá aí na série está aí na cena que
vocês vêm eles se reúnem já se olha os
mortos vivos vão invadir aqui é esse o
nosso território vai matar todo mundo
sabe por quê
porque os nossos exércitos
individualmente não são fortes o
suficiente
a gente precisa se juntar e aí o
objetivo dela queria tomar o reú trono
de ferro passa a ser sobreviver e ela
aceita
sabe por quê porque se você há 10 15 20
anos atrás queria ser presidente do
brasil e você nunca se envolveu com
política e desistiu disso você precisa
mudar de objetivo e você precisa ter um
objetivo igualmente grande
aprenda a desistir das sombrinhas
amarelas ou daquilo que não faz mais
sentido para você e eu termino a lista
de personagens que nos inspiram com
raiva o rar vem
o rafael é um advogado para lançar
escute que é a série que fala do dos
principais escritórios de advocacia dos
estados unidos e um rabo de todos eles é
o único único personagem que realmente
cria um ele cria um personagem pra ser
interpretado ele criou uma persona forte
sabe por quê porque se eu preciso ser
forte é preciso parecer ser forte
antes de ser alguma coisa eu preciso
parecer ser essa coisa errada e pensa no
jeito de vestir e falar por mais que
vocês não gostem
vocês precisam se preocupar com isso
porque as pessoas vão te julgar pelo
jeito de vestir pelo jeito de andar pelo
jeito de falar a composição do
personagem é uma composição teatral eu
penso eu quero ser forte eu quero ser
determinado eu quero ter sucesso como é
que eu tenho que olhar para as pessoas
verem essa força em mim porque quando eu
tô falando de empreendedorismo eu estou
falando que o seu cliente precisa ver a
força em você
então se eu tenho uma pequena loja de
sapatos uma pequena loja numa portinha
eu não me comporto como um grande
executivo eu nunca você o maior se ou do
mundo porque o nome
um pouco como tal eu preciso agir como
executivo falar como executivo me vestir
como executivo para que eu consiga
chegar lá no meu objetivo final
esses cinco personagens que são os
personagens que não me ensinaram como
ser mais forte que me ensinaram como
talvez eu precise entrar no mercado
eles contam uma coisa quando eu tô lá
vendo série no final de semana no meu
tempo livre eu tô vendo uma série de
influências
vocês acham que pra compor o hafei por
exemplo o ator não investigou milhares
de se ouvir como eles falavam e se
portavam a gente está vendo uma
compilação de atitudes
a gente está vendo um trabalho de
dramatização e composição enorme
complexo e se a gente não usar esse
trabalho para a luz influenciar e para
formatar nossos personagens
a gente vai ter mais dificuldade porque
eles são completos a gente acompanhe a
trajetória deles a gente vê como eles
nascem e como eles se desenvolvem
pessoal todos vocês são personagens
vocês querendo ou não as pessoas
atribuem personagens a vocês e vocês
podem escolher qualquer personagem de
qualquer série de qualquer filme
qualquer um
vocês podem escolher a combinação que
vocês quiserem com uma condição apenas
não esqueçam a voz interior de vocês
abandonem as sombrinhas amarelas lembrem
que vocês querem ser grandes que vocês
não querem ser o próximo carro apenas e
aí nessa composição para ter sucesso
nesse jogo da vida que estamos todos
jogando a final
eu preciso interpretar esse personagem
conscientemente
eu preciso olhar no espelho e entender
como eu tenho que olhar como eu tenho
que falar como eu tenho que me vestir
qual imagem eu quero passar vai ter
sucesso quem interpretar esse personagem
de forma mais consciente
eu convido todos vocês a partir de agora
a comporem esses personagens aprimorarem
eles a olharem as séries e falar eu
quero ser como
de cara o que ele tem para ensinar como
é que eu posso me tornar um personagem
mais forte e mais pronto pra entender
essa é a mensagem de hoje
boa sorte a todos vocês nas suas
composições
[Aplausos]